uh good evening members uh
members of the public officers can i
welcome you to this uh planning meeting
of the 19th of january
um if it's not too late i know we're
three weeks into the new year but i know
we've seen each other on different play
you have different meetings but happy
new year to you all
a safe one and hopefully we move on
getting rid of this
virus and so forth
i'd like to welcome
councillor everett
onto the planning and also welcome back
to councillor wing
um
i'm sure council
everett has been on planning before
many times i thought so i thought so
regarding masks i'm sure you know
we we are
due to wear them still
yep
the lifting of the masks doesn't happen
until next week
so please
if you wouldn't mind doing that i know
it's difficult for me because as you
know i talk a lot
we are being live streamed so um
housekeeping and so forth
which brings me on to that
if the fire alarm is activated please
vacate the offices via the stairs either
through the security door which is
behind me on this time
or
the doors opposite the lifts in the
foyer please of course do not use the
lifts and assemble on holy square green
opposite the council offices
and when it's safe to do so
the officers will come and get you and
bring you back in
does anybody uh this evening
wish to film this meeting
i can't see any thank you very much
i also would ask members and members of
the public please do not
use your phones turn them to silent
do not make calls or take calls whilst
in
the chamber
thank you
members requesting to speak under
council procedure rule 20.1
item 5c
councillor
scoby
agreement council scoby
public speaking the following
application has been reserved for public
speaking would members please strike
through and make a note the item which
again is 5c
274 north dam road margate
agenda item one i have apologies at the
moment from councillor rozewski is there
any other
member
not with us tonight
no okay thank you
uh agenda item 2 declarations of
interest which i believe there is from
councillor wing
yes chair
item 5c
the company involved is actually my
accountant and i have signed their
petition
thank you for that counselor wing and i
will ask you to leave the chamber when
we come to that item
[Music]
agenda item three a minutes at the
planning committee meeting which was
held on the 15th of december do members
agree that the minutes of that meeting
are correct and approved and signed by
myself
could i have a proposal please
counselor alban a seconder
councillor paul moore do you all agree
thank you members
uh point of information uh regarding
item 5a i'm going to hand over to
mr livingston our planning applications
manager
thank you chair um as mentioned point of
information for members about agenda
item 5a which is the land adjacent to
475 margate road broad stairs
so a couple of updates to two conditions
condition two
uh two of the plans reference need to be
updated to reflect the amended
landscaping plan
and therefore the site plan which is
referenced
two zero eight nine zero zero revision
p01 is updated to p02 which was received
on the 11th of january 2022 and the hard
surfacing plan which is reference
208150 revision p01 is updated to p02
received on the same day the 11th of
january
and those are the plans that were
submitted and also the ones that are on
the council's website and therefore the
condition is corrected that's before
members
on condition three uh which required
details of the means of foul and surface
water drainage to be submitted prior to
the commencement of development southern
water provided an additional comment on
the application prior to the meeting
this evening confirming that the
proposed drainage layout provided with
the application originally is acceptable
and therefore condition three is updated
to require that the development shall be
constructed in accordance with the
submitted drainage strategy plan
numbered
six one one twos two three c zero zero
one p three received on the 23rd of
september 2021.
uh the recommendation to members is
therefore updated uh to reflect the
changes to conditions two and three and
on an additional point uh the report for
that item uh number five a uh
incorrectly identifies the location of
the site uh in the moses montefiore ward
uh when it falls within saint peter's uh
due to an administrative error so
apologies for that thank you chair
uh thank you ian
moving on to agenda item four i would
ask the plan officer to outline the
report and that is
thank you emma
thank you chairman this is an
application for a non-material amendment
um the site is located here in margaret
high street on the corner of the high
street with new streets
and the application has come before
members the senate district council is
the applicant
so the consideration is whether this is
a non-material change to the original
proposal so this is the site here this
building here
and this is a closer view of the
building so the application that was
previously considered was for the
replacement of the existing windows
within the front and side elevation of
the buildings
um and so you can see these are the
existing wind the existing windows
within the building on the front
elevation onto the high street and these
are um also within the front elevation
and then you can see the side elevation
windows
here as well
and then again the side elevation onto
new street the existing windows
so this was the approved front elevation
so it was to replace the existing
windows from um timber to aluminium and
it could show you can see the window
design with
three window panes and the glazing bars
through the center
a larger window at ground floor level
and smaller windows above and the
proposal is to alter the um proportions
of these panes within these windows so
this is the approved plan and this is
now the proposed plan
so the difference is the proportions of
the panes
within the lower middle and and top
section of the window so the actual
opening the oval opening of the window
remains the same in terms of the width
and the height and the window design
remains the same so it's just literally
the the proportions of these that are
changing so on the first floor level the
top frame is becoming eight centimeters
deeper the middle 17.4 centimeters
smaller and the bottom frame 3.9
centimeters deeper and then on the
second floor windows
is a difference of 2.4 centimeters to
the top pane seven centimeters to
the middle and 3.5 centimeters to the
lower frame um so it's considered that
overall given the overall um
size of the building and the alterations
to the windows and the fact that the the
actual size of the opening remains the
same the window design remains the same
and the only difference is is just a
proportion of the frames that the
proposal is a non-material change to the
original consent and therefore it's
recommended for approval thank you
uh thank you emma i recommend the
officers
recommendation is adopted could the vice
chair please second or second nature
thank you very much members councilman
yeah thank you chair um
i can't see anything wrong with this
what's whatsoever
the the alterations are minimal
um
it doesn't really affect the
conservation area any more than the than
the original application
so i i'm mindful to approve thank you
chair
thank you councilman
councillor bayford
sorry thank you chair yeah i agree with
councillor auburn and to be honest the
sooner this um progresses and is used
for the purpose it's intended the better
so i shall certainly be supporting this
thank you
thank you
any other members wish
counselling uh i certainly support it as
well as a previous owner of a greater
enlisted building and presently with a
house in a conservation zone it's good
to see that we've got some forward
thinking and we're trying to use modern
materials within a conservation zone to
increase our
our climate emergency uh agenda
thank you for answering
any other members wish to comment
okay members thank you i'm going to put
this to the vote
those in a favor please show
any against
abstentions
no that is carried thank you very much
thank you members um agenda item 5
schedule of planning applications and
public speaking any site visits
that
take place or arrange from tonight will
take place on friday the 4th
of
february 2022.
agenda item 5c is the application which
is for refusal
r03274
north down road
margate now i do have as i mentioned a
member of the public is
going to speak
yes sir sorry
counselor wing has left i was about to
come into that
member of the public i believe
speaking
right now i did a
pub
okay no it's got down here but i read it
out the problem doesn't matter it
doesn't matter
under twenty point one counts of scopy
thank you chairman
um
as one of the local councillors i'm
always pleased to see improvements in
properties in our ward
john michael of
mph accountants has owned the premises
since 1977.
i remember the shop well it was
chapman's bakery and then later kent
scuba
the shop was rather tatty and
unappealing like the properties either
side some opposite and not really
significant of significant historic
interest
and is not listed referred to or stated
as being so in the management plan
appendix 2.
when kent scuba decided to move out of
the shop mr michael took the opportunity
to move his business from upstairs and
gain the advantage of a shop front for
his business
he used the firm to produce a better
design and enhance the building for
disabled access and improve the quality
of the front in terms of materials
maintenance and thermal properties all
very important in terms of
improving the carbon footprint of the
building and making it better for
workers and everybody
in terms of disabled access
mr michael had not been informed by tdc
the local planning authority that his
premises were in a conservation area
the firm who undertook the cons design
and construction was similarly unaware
of it being in a conservation area this
is a significant fact
mr michael has always been willing to
work with
tdc planning department
when he's in he was informed that the
premises would not be granted planning
permission by an enforcement officer he
was surprised
as the officer seemed to have prejudiced
the application with a simple eye test
he attempted to get pre-planning uh
approval and paid an appropriate fee
but this was never completed and
eventually the fee was refunded
he then put the retrospective
application you now have before you
mr michael has over 100 letters of
support from local residents and
businesses to support his application
i would ask you this evening to use your
common sense and approve the application
for retrospective planning commission
and support this important local
business thank you
thank you councillor scoby um
i'll ask the planning officer which is
annabelle please to outline the report
thank you thank you chair
so this is the application site outlined
in red
so as has been said it's a retrospective
application for a replacement shop front
so this is an aerial photograph of the
site we have crawford gardens to the
side here north down road running along
the top here
and this is the application site
the application site is within the north
down road conservation area and whilst
it is not a listed building in its own
right it's described in the north down
road conservation area appraisal as a
positive unlisted building so there is
weight given to it in that document as
being of some historic significance
so this is the actual photograph of the
previous shot front
and whilst at some point there has been
this overly large
fascia sign placed on the
shop front it can be seen that the shop
front was traditional in appearance
it had store risers
transom windows to the top here
it actually slopes away
from
the pavement and isn't flush
in the way modern shop fronts tend to be
and it has the large top window the door
and a small glass display cabinet
so it has many things that you might
expect to see in a traditional shop
front
and this is enough a view of it and you
can see it in the context of the shop
fronts surrounding it
and again you can see
without the the large fascia sign that
it is very much a traditional shop front
and its traditional materials and
traditional design
and again just enough a
lot longer view of the shop front
surrounding it
so this is the site
with the previous shop front
and this
pearl is also a traditional shop front
which was granted for consent in 2015
and this site is reflections is also
traditional shop fronts which you can
see has recessed doorways
and has character and store risers
to the bottom
so looking at some photographs now is
the shop front that's been installed
it's this shop front here
excuse me
so as can be seen it's it is modern in
appearance
and it now sits flush
to the pavement so that recessed
a sort of
slanted shop front has gone
and it could be argued that they have
attempted
to put trans some windows to the top
here but the proportions
are not in keeping with what would be
expected in a traditional
shop front and we are looking at
aluminium
materials
etc
one positive that has come about in
terms of design is the removal of that
overly large faces sign
again this is a view of this
looking up north down road this is the
shop front in question
this is reflections that we saw
previously and this is quite traditional
in character as you can see the recessed
doors
the large windows the transom windows to
the top
and this is looking and comparing the
shop front that we're considering
tonight is here on the right and this is
pearl
and as i said before this was actually
granted consent it was a modern more
modern uh shop front again aluminium but
it was granted consent to go back to a
timber
and a more traditional appearance in
2015 and that was considered to be a
welcome benefit to the character and
appearance of the shop front
um these are some shop fronts just to
give members some more context on the
opposite side of
north down road
opposite the site
but so it is appreciated there is a mix
of shop fronts and different designs and
characters
within the conservation area
so this is the elevation of
it says existing but as we know it is a
retrospective application so this was a
previous shop front
um you can see here
again the over large fascia sign but
generally the transom windows the
historic
stall riser and the small glass cabinet
display cabinet
to the right of the door
this is the ground floor of that
previous shop front part ground floor of
the building so you can see it was a
large shot front that projected
it's
um
turned away
at an angle from
the pavement
the doorway can be seen there and that
small traditional feature of the display
window on the opposite side of the door
can be seen
this is the shop front
that's in place now
it is
considered by officers to lack the
finesse of
the traditional shop front it is now
flush to the pavement
and it is aluminium
in nature
in materials so
it is a non-traditional material but
not necessarily unacceptable in a
conservation area but in terms of what
was there before and the design that's
come forward
with this shop front it is considered to
add and have an adverse impact on the
character appearance of the conservation
area
and again just looking at the ground
floor you can see it is now lost
the
glass
small glass uh display window that was
situated by the door and it is now flush
to the pavement
so
to summarize members
it the site does lie with the north
within the north down road conservation
area it isn't listed but it is um
acknowledged to be a a building
certainly of historic interest and it
was a positive
um listed building in the conservation
area appraisal
members will know that it is the duty
of the council as a local planning
authority to preserve or enhance the air
respective your character and appearance
the alterations to this shop front have
result in the loss of the
shop front that was constructed from
traditional materials and had a very
traditional design
the new shop front has resulted in some
public benefits and that has to be
acknowledged and weighed against any
harm that's considered to be
caused by the installation of shop front
so those benefits include improved
security
increased thermal efficiency efficiency
and accessibility
however it's not been adequately
demonstrated that these benefits could
not have been achieved
um through the adaptation of the
previous shop front or the use of more
sympathetic materials and design
so
these benefits are considered to be
outweighed
by the harm that is um caused to catch
an appearance of the
conservation area by the
installation of this shop front
so it is concluded by officers that the
replacement shop by virtue of its modern
design and materials that does fail to
preserve the architecture and historic
merit of the actual building itself as
well as detracting from the special
character of the significance of the
conservation area which uh both it was a
designated heritage assets so the
recommendation is for refusal
thank you chair
thank you annabelle i move the officer's
recommendation is adopted could the vice
chair please second i'll second thank
you uh thank you council mccook members
few hands going up here um i'd take
ladies first councillor bayford
thank you chair i have to say
that there is quite a variety of
different shop fronts i don't find it
particularly unattractive and there are
a lot of benefits
so
i accept that it isn't traditional in
the way that
the previous shopfront was but
i personally can't see a lot of harm and
i think i would like to approve this
thank you
thank you uh councillor auburn
take this one
yeah thank you chair um
as
councillor bae first mentioned uh
you know i lived just i lived off of
north down road for quite a number of
years
and used north down road on a regular
basis
and uh there's always been an eclectic
mix
of
shop fronts and different businesses etc
etc etc
um
i i i don't mean to laugh but to
actually use the word finesse for north
down road is slightly uh slightly a bit
over the top um
could i ask if we could have the the
current
photograph of how it is at the moment
yeah that'd do can you go back to that
one yeah
now
listening to what the officer said about
uh
the next door shop front about it being
done and having a nice uh and how it was
done and the application was was was
approved
since then they put these large wooden
planters outside which
takes
the view
and and the uh
site of that shop front it you know you
stand in front of it it completely
destroys it
so
looking at looking at the frontage goes
along
the applicant could also do the same
there if it was the same eye it would be
permitted development so even if you had
a nice shop front in it as what you
would
or if you wanted to retain it that too
would detract from that shop front um
i go along with with councillor bayford
and um
i'm mindful to support the application
chair thank you
thank you councillor heart
thank you chair well i'm at odds with
everybody here because um
i think it looked appalling and i think
it should be as it was um i think it's a
shame to lose some of these historic
pieces of shop front and just to grab a
couple of extra square feet of footage
to put your desk in i think it's quite a
shame um i do agree with
council auburn i think those planters
shouldn't be there at all but and that
does detract from the view down the
street but i do think it's a shame that
people
don't have the ability to look on the
local um council offices um
what is a conservation area it's not
hard to work it out a builder can do it
very easily i can do it anyone here can
do it and for him to turn around saying
he didn't know he's just just appalling
absolutely appalling it's not an excuse
it's just laziness or trying to
turn around and say i'll do it
retrospectively and i think that's very
lazy and absolutely dishonest to be fair
and i think it should be back be put
back to it as it was thank you
thank you council heart uh
councillor keane
thank you
um
yeah i'm also a ward councillor in this
area so i know north down road well and
there is a huge mix of different
buildings generally because of the
conservation area i'm in favour of
keeping the original features but a
couple of things occur to me with this
one it wasn't well kept in the past so
you know it it actually does look better
than it used to although more modern
it does increase accessibility which i
think is something very important today
but also
how come the sign for the scuba sign was
never flagged up in a conservation area
as being inappropriate because as i say
i think that's an improvement on that
and i will be supporting um it going
through against the motion thank you
thank you cancer over it
thank you chair yeah i mean what
concerns me is that we're if we're
asking the applicant to return the site
to its previous state then he would be
fully entitled to return the previous
fascia board which i think is a is a
bigger um
a bigger in inappropriate feature in the
area and the shop front is installed so
i share what counselor keane's views
about concerns about how that arrived in
the first place perhaps it was there
before the conservation area was brought
in
but we clearly don't want to go back to
that i mean it does seem to me that it's
a shame that um the applicant didn't
engage with the council at an earlier
stage because i'm sure that there was a
better compromise that could have been
reached
um but here we are and it seems to me
disproportionate to force them to go
back to what was there
thank you council paul moore
yes thank you chair
sadly i'm in the opinion as councillor
heart
a retrospective application means
they've done something without
permission and now they're applying for
it because they've been caught out
the fact that the property was in
disrepair well that's the owners fault
not our fault so we're not to blame for
being redone i think the original was
far better um
you could argue as uh council everett
says about the oversized scuba board but
then that was done before and and we're
not talking about before we're talking
about now
i i don't think it's an attractive
proposal
i think as you say if they've been
engaging with the council we could have
had a better compromise better materials
you could have used other materials to
via thermal
savings and things like that so i'll be
voting against this one
thank you
uh do i see any other members wish to
speak
i don't okay uh
members it's time for you to vote um
and the recommendation as you're aware
is for refusal
so those who are in favor of the
officer's recommendation with a plea
show of the hands for refusal
thank you
those against the officer's
recommendation
thank you any abstentions
right the officer's recommendation has
fallen
so
just bear with me as always for a moment
i'm going to hand over to mr livingston
thank you
thank you chair so in terms of um
approving the application as members are
aware
reasons need to be given for approving
an application against the
recommendation of of officers and just
to summarize um what members have stated
um i think if a member wants to move a
motion that consider the benefits the
new shop front um specifically what's
been mentioned sort of getting getting
across all the members comments was
thermal efficiency accessibility and a
reduced size of the fascia would
outweigh any identified harm to the
north down road conservation area thank
you
thank you uh members to
does anybody i know
how are you how unusual is that
cancer auburn your proposal please yeah
take it okay
that's you're fine uh could i have a
second to please councillor bayford
right you've heard uh
the proposal of cancer
those agree
please show
to approve
okay against
that thank you members that has been
carried
thank you for that one
if you bear with us we will go and try
and find counselor keen
[Music]
i know i know
i'm a year older since i saw you last
thank you councillor wing no doubt it
was cold out there
yetis
right that concludes the public speaking
for this meeting i'm going to call on
james who's got a different face on
tonight
to read out the remainder the planning
applications if a member wishes to
reserve an application to speak will
they please
call out as she reads thank you
thank you okay so um 5a is
thank you land adjacent to 475 margate
road broadstairs
and
5b numbers 4 to 15 and 19 to 23 royal
crescent saint augustine's road ramsgate
okay thank you katie um
right
can i have a proposer for those that
aren't going to be spoken about tonight
please
i don't agree
i am i always do
yeah there must be something about you
steve um
secular please
send me a
count counselor wing i called your
councillor king again just now i do
apologize members in favor
okay
thank you
moving over to officer on
the margate road application please
thank you chairman the application site
is outlined in red here so it's within
the um tesco um site up at westwood
cross so you can see the site is here
this is the existing petrol station
this is the tesco's
unit
this is broadcast retail park area here
you can see margate road running along
this area here
so this is a aerial view of the sites
the the site is this um area here that's
currently soft landscaped
and then a closer view of this you can
see there's a footpath an existing
footpath that runs along from margate
road into um buses retail park you can
see the existing internal access
roundabout and
access would be from this internal road
and then a closer view again so and
there are some trees on the site so you
can see in this aerial view there's a
group of trees in this location here and
in this location here so in the next few
photos i will show you the view is taken
from this footpath looking towards the
site
so this is the view from that footpath
foot path and looking towards the site
and so the site extends right to this
part here where you can see the
retaining wall running around the edge
of the site you can see the existing
roundabout on the right hand side
and then this is showing that corner so
this is now the footpath leading into
broadcast retail park an existing tree
in this location here so this tree is to
be retained
and then this is again looking from the
footpath across to margate road in the
distance and you can see and the
existing trees on this boundary here so
you can see it's currently just um
just grasped on this site so one of the
issues is that the loss of this open
space whether that's a concern
um and and then generally the
development of the site and and the
impact on the area
so again looking from these photos are
now taken from margate road so from this
point here this is a different different
day you can see it's a little bit
foggier um so this is again the footpath
that runs through the site this is on
the right hand side the footpath so in
this area here it's proposed to retain
this tree here this tree on the right
hand side is is being removed and it's
also proposed some new tree planting
along this area which you'll see later
on the landscaping plan and also the
installation of some benches along this
area here which will
help
in terms of amenity for people wishing
to sit and eat lunch
and this view is taken from margaret
road again looking towards the site you
can see the existing
trees along this boundary here so some
of these trees are removed and some are
being retained so i'll just show you a
closer view so this tree on the left is
being removed
these two trees here are being retained
and this group um on the right are being
removed
so again that's that's a view of the
ones being removed so these are all
birch trees you can see they're quite
small um small trees not overly mature
um none of these trees are considered
worthy of protection through a tpo
so this is the site layout you can see
on the plan the existing trees and the
footpath that currently runs through the
site and the
there's also an existing soak away in
this area here so this area can't be
developed so you'll see later on again
through the landscaping plan that we're
looking to
enhance this area through a wildflower
growing area which will help with
biodiversity so you'll see that later on
the plan so this is the proposed layout
plan the applications for
a single commercial unit restaurant um
coffee shop use with a drive-through so
the access comes off from the internal
roundabout and this road here would be
the the drive-through link that runs
around the unit
and you can see the unit is is the area
in purple here with um
a storage area
to the north of the slide and this area
here is external seating area associated
with the unit
you can see to the to the bottom of the
slide this would be um parking
provisions there's 22 car parking spaces
being provided
including some disabled spaces and five
cycle
cycle hoops for
storing of bicycles for staff and and
patrons of the site
and there's a pedestrian link that would
run off the existing link
that will connect to the site and
there's also a pedestrian link from
margaret road that would go across the
drive through to the site as well
this area here's the proposed bin store
which will be
enclosed by some hedging
and you can see the areas in green which
is showing the the soft landscaping
around the edge of the site and between
the the drive-through road and the
development
and then this area here is the area
that's proposed for the wildflower
meadow so this is over the existing um
soakaway areas
um in terms of the trees you can see a
few of the tree planted but again it's
clearer on the landscaping plan later on
so the site is located within westwood
town centre it's in a primary shopping
area and it's an area allocated as
secondary frontage so the proposal is a
sewer generous use on the basis that
there's a drive-through associated with
restaurant use
but as a commercial use within the town
centre there's there's no principal
objection to the development this site
for a commercial unit um the only
consideration is whether the the need
for the residential i'm not residing so
the need for the commercial unit um and
the the job creation that would result
from that um whether that outweighs any
harm to the the area from the the
development of the site
so
in terms of the uses it's proposed
within the application that there would
be 30 full-time jobs created through the
development of 40 part-time jobs so
there is a real economic benefit through
through the development of this site and
the creation of this this uh
restaurant unit
so in terms of the actual elevations you
can see here is a typical commercial
unit that's typical of the of the design
of units we see up at westwood so it's
quite modern
um the materials being used are black
brown and cream metal cladding with
black and red aluminium framed windows
and doors so whilst single store it's
quite a a tall unit
you can see this this elevation is
fronting onto margate road um and onto
the drive through link
so you can see there's large elements of
glazing within this this elevation
and then this is the elevation facing
towards the footpath and the car park
area
again large elements of glazing within
it with the
potential
future signage within the space above
and then this would look towards the
internal roundabout so towards the
access into the site
and then this is the view that looks on
to the roundabout onto margate road so
this this elevation is is quite blank um
unfortunately there's always going to be
one elevation
that doesn't have um fenestration within
it because this area is the storage yard
area and it contains the mechanical
equipment needed for the unit so
as you'll see later in the landscaping
plan the lasek landscaping plan does
show that there will be plants in front
of this to try and soften this elevation
so this is the
floor plan for the unit so just a large
unit and again this is the area here
that has um the cold room and external
yard area so this this has more of the
blank frontage on this side but all
other three elevations have large areas
of glazing so very active frontages um
on all three
three elevations
and then
um
so this is just again just showing
showing the layout just before i go on
to um the landscaping plans so this is a
hard
landscaping plan so this is showing that
the um parking area would be tarmacked
but the area the drive-through road that
runs around along with the areas for the
external
seating area would be paved so there
would be of um some variation in the
hard surfacing material so the fact we
have achieved um permeable paving
running around the site here that's um
beneficial compared to the the tarmac
and then this is the soft landscaping
plan so this was amended during the
course of the application following
concerns raised with the loss of the
trees
so this plan is showing the retention of
of
these two trees along the front of the
site that i showed you in the photos
earlier so these are two cherry trees
that have been retained
and oak tree has been retained in this
location here and this is a line tree
that's being retained in this corner
here so those four trees being retained
and the amended landscaping plan is now
showing additional tree plants in to
compensate the loss of the
other trees that were having to be
removed in order to
get the drive-through road running
around the site because they were too
close to the development so 10 trees are
now proposed within the development
in addition to that there's the hedge
planting in this location here running
around the refuge stores hedge planting
along the sides of the
existing footpath
the benches are shown in this location
here so you have three benches running
along the footpath and you can see the
wildflower meadow area and then along
this area here this is where there was
quite a blank frontage that elevation so
there's now going to be planting in this
area here to soften it and again there's
planting close to
the existing brick wall so whilst the
area is soft landscaped at the moment
and there will be
a lot of that there will be enhancements
as well to biodiversity um through the
planting of native native species around
the site
and also the better use of this land as
a external means he land with the
wildflower meadow and then also the just
the general use of the land through
having the the benches um
because there's there's limited space
for this within within west return
center so it's useful to have these sort
of spaces
so
one of the considerations was to do with
air quality so in terms of electric
vehicle charging they have proposed to
provide the electric vehicle charging
off-site so this would be um outside the
site within the existing tesco car park
or broadcast retail park car park so a
legal agreement has been submitted
signed legal agreement with the
development with the application sorry
that includes the provision of three
electric vehicle charging spaces either
within this car park area here or within
this car park area here and that's to be
provided within 12 months of the unit
coming into use
in terms of the impact on neighboring
properties i'll just go back to
actually i might go back sorry to the
first plan
so here you can see the distance the
nearest neighboring property so the this
is the nearest neighboring property to
the site here it's 88 meters from the
development
um
so in terms of the impact the impacts
considered were the impact on from noise
and disturbance of the development and
from light pollution
so in terms of noise and disturbance
it's proposed that the unit would be
open from six in the morning till eleven
at night um seven days a week with
deliveries taking place between six in
the morning and five o'clock at night
and and these hours are restricted
through condition and the customer order
point is 65 meters from the nearest
dwelling and the parking areas is at
least 35 meters away
so
it was
environmental health were consulted and
they advised that no noise assessment
was necessary
given the fact that the site is located
within an existing commercial area and
there's the mcdonald's unit which is
opposite the site here
which is a 24-hour unit and obviously
the petrol station which is open so
there's other commercial units and
tesco's as well which are 24-hour units
and already creating noise so it's not
considered that this unit given the
restricted hours of use would result in
significant harm from noise and
disturbance to the nearest neighboring
property
and in terms of lights as well lights
are proposed within the car park area so
i'll just go back to the
block plan
so there's some new lights um lamp posts
that propose within
the
sites along the boundaries but these
would all be downward facing light so
considered to be no light pollution um
impact on neighbours and obviously given
the distance there's no impact in terms
of light outlook or any of those um
issues that we would normally consider
when when looking at living conditions
in terms of the impact on highways
highways have raised no concerns with
the provision of the 22 parking spaces
um
they consider that there are likely to
be linked trips with with people coming
out to west across anyway that would be
shopping and then potentially would you
be using this unit so the actual
provision of the unit is unlikely to
result in
a significant increase in vehicle
movements um in in the town centre um
and they have proposed recommended that
the pedestrian links be provided so this
this wasn't an amendment to the scheme
that allows for a pedestrian could cross
the drive through um and obviously
there's a link that comes from the site
onto the existing footpath so these were
recommended by highways through the
application
and and as mentioned there's the cycle
parking and the electric vehicle
charging so on highways have no concerns
with the impact on on highway safety
and in terms of
drainage um
you heard earlier that southern water
have now raised no objections so a
drainage strategy was submitted with the
application so this is the drainage
strategy which was just showing that the
development would connect onto the
existing foul sewer that runs along
margate road and that the area here
which is the um the soakaway area that
all surface water drains would just soak
away soak into that area so um southern
water have removed the need for a
drainage um plan to be submitted as a
pre-commencement condition and are just
happy with this drainage strategy so
that has now been amended
so um so overall the the site is in
principle acceptable given the fact it's
located within the the town centre and
is a commercial unit in accordance with
the policy
in terms of the appearance of the
building it's a typical um commercial um
design that's in keeping with the the
character of the area which is of modern
commercial developments
there's um going to be limited impacts
on neighboring immunity and highways are
phrased no concerns
and and there is a legal agreement that
secures the electric vehicle charging
spaces off-site
so it's recommended for approval on the
basis that this will result in economic
benefits for the area and these will
outweigh the limited
environmental harm especially given the
provision of the amended landscaping
plan which um achieves some enhancements
to biodiversity and new tree planting
thank you
uh thank you for that emma i move uh the
officer's recommendation which you've
heard is for approval be adopted
can i have a second please
i'll second that chair thank you council
comic cook council ghana
thank you yeah and thank you emma for
the that presentation um
yeah as was mentioned i've got a few
things a few concerns i just wanted to
bring to the planning committee on this
application
um as ian mentioned earlier this is
incredibly marked has been in samosi's
montefiore board so
i or any of the other town councillors
in broad says on which this is on the
on the border
and bought it to the attention of the
town council so the town council hadn't
had a chance to comment on it which i'm
sure they they would have
but putting that aside
one my my concerns were around
the
impact on the biodiversity and the loss
of trees
but also the increase in the traffic and
the impact on the air quality
where most of the presentation was
talking about this in isolation
this new drive-through restaurant
takeaway in isolation but
on within 100 meters of that site
there's the already existing mcdonald's
which has just had a
application approved to increase
to three lanes of traffic
um to
enter the drive through which is going
to increase the traffic there
and
some of us will probably be aware that
on the other side of
the mcdonald's
there's a new starbucks drive through
starbucks stroke restaurant being built
which of course is also going to
increase the traffic and have an adverse
effect on the air quality
so while
i did note in the report that um
air quality assessment and emissions
mitigation assessment was not required
because of the size of the development
when you add all of these new
the the existing mcdonald's and these
new drive-throughs there is going to be
a quite serious adverse
impact on the air quality and emissions
for the area this is
i mean i'm i'm sure most of us are very
familiar with this area it is very busy
um because you know it's accessing to
westwood cross to the tescos to
sainsbury's tesco's
um
garage it is very busy and i and i think
it is gonna
become a lot busier and one thing
that i've noticed certainly with
the other mcdonald's which is
recently opened down the road
um
from here is the the increase in
home delivery
um
drivers who don't seem to be allowed to
go in
they have to park outside to then walk
in to collect and i think this needs
also to be taken into consideration
because there there will be an increase
in traffic and
and um emissions there
um
now
as far as the westward town centre
this being in westwood town centre and
the strategy associated with it
i know that we're looking as part of the
local plan review
to
increase
or to try and encourage people certainly
to use their bikes and to walk in
between the sites of westwood
um i don't think this proliferation this
this application adding to the others
is gonna either help that or make it any
more pleasant to encourage people to
want to walk from tesco's to westwood
cross or or sainsbury's or any other
supermarkets that are available to walk
across so
i have a concern about
this becoming
un
unsafe health wise
for walkers and cyclists
and one thing that also isn't
noted in the report and i haven't seen a
comment
from kent police
uh because often we get report on
antisocial behavior and again i guess
with one with these individual sites
taken in isolation
there they might not be considered a
problem but
with
soon to be
possibly three of these
there must be an increase in concern
about antisocial behavior
you meant we meant you mentioned the
the houses that are quite close close by
um i think
i guess this is just another layer of
of um trouble and bother for them in
terms of the traffic and air pollution
i've i've talked about but the light
pollution and and everything else is
going to worry them um
it's it's unfortunate for them i guess
they've chosen to live near a
near a shopping center but
it's just another level of of of impact
on on those
um the biodiversity
aspect
i mean i am i'm
on the plus side i'm pleased that they
have been persuaded
to plant a few more
uh
trees around the site but this is
the last sort of on that tesco's
spaced area this is the last group bit
of green that that exists up there
and while the trees were mentioned there
is quite a large um
a large hedge that was sort of
overlooked a little bit that is just as
important certainly to the
the birds who are when they are flying
around they're looking for somewhere to
land there's not that many hedges left
for them to land in so i'm sure that
would be ought to be
ought to be considered
um
i think
i believe this plot of land
they had before this application went in
been considering
you know enhancing it by
biodiversity-wise
biodiversity-wise to form part of the
wildlife life corridor that's trying to
be created
um
in patches across there and i just think
i mean it's unfortunate for these
applicants but it's
in summary i think it's the final straw
on that patch that's broken the um
broken the back of allowing any more of
these type of developments anymore so
now i've got i'll be interested to hear
what others have got to say about it but
i do believe this
this this is a step too far for
for that area as far as drive-throughs
air quality and everything else is
considered
thank you
uh thank you council ghana i will just
touch what you mentioned about some
moses montefori ward was
uh i spotted that um and i am aware it
was
an error which can happen and i think uh
totally understand what you're saying
but i think if members do look at their
lists you know where you live
um and that's not being rude to you if
you don't mind me saying that
no thank you right a few hands up um
i think cancer
that's the heart i'll go for counselor
heart
thank you chair um
i do agree
um
with my colleague there but i i do have
a couple of concerns
um firstly
if water runs off that site and goes
into the
drainage system there
does that have an oil trap in it and a
fuel trap to take away those before they
go into the ground water
secondly if you're going to put paving
in or pavias around the edge that then
becomes an area where oils and
petrols can leak into the soil if you
have a hard surface like
tarmac it can then go into that overflow
system and that's not a problem but if
that should
i believe have an oil trap in it because
if you had something
which was
uh i don't know
a major site where you had a transfer
station you have to have separate things
to take out separate wastes and oils and
spillages well that's the same sort of
design really that you could actually
put into these and remove those before
they go into the ground walk ground
totally does that have it will it have
it and what about the
the pavers but it's just going to go
straight into the ground
thank you
i i don't know the answer i'm afraid i
don't know the answer to whether there's
a
oil trap in it i mean it's it's an area
of heart of of soft landscapes there at
the moment there's no concerns being
raised from southern water like i say
the drainage pan before you is just
showing that the water would drain from
the hard surface area into that space
which is quite a substantial area
but yeah i don't know sorry
sorry chip but maybe that should be
included into that sort of plan if
they're going to have these areas where
it's going to run into quite
considerable water into an area they
should have an oil trap or a fuel trap
just to stop it going into the main
ground because all you're doing is just
contaminating the ground further and
further and that's what we're trying to
avoid really
uh thank you sahar council paul moore
yes thank you chair i think council
garner and council heart have covered
all the salient points i was going to
raise i do have concerns with this
development i think it's the thing of
the wedge of losing a green a green
woods area
it was planned previously to be part of
the biodiversity so that we could have
an area where
birds and insects migrating could hop
leap and jump to different areas and
there are other commercial units there
which they could heavily invest in and
use those so some of them are shut now
they could be used i think this is just
um a money spin for someone and i'm not
happy with it at all thank you chair
uh thank you councilman yes uh mrs
liminson come back
hi i just want to come back on the
drainage points that have been raised so
the drainage plan that you can see in
front of you um you'll be able to see
the um annotation um which
is is in the middle of the the surface
area where it's indicating a an
interceptor with regards to the drainage
that's occurring on the site from the
hard surfacing so
it's how can i put it at the um to the
south of um
actually
yeah
so where the mouse is um now it's it's
got the indication of
of what's occurring there you can also
see the the red showing the points
which is then goes into the existing
uh drainage network so you can see
there's the the manholes and then the
main drain which runs along the road so
in terms of where things are draining to
on that hard surface it's not being put
to infiltrate to the ground and i think
that's obviously one of the key points
in terms of the issue with regards to
where it is in terms of groundwater what
i will do is uh in between other
questions i'll just check where this
site is in relation to the groundwater
source protection zone but with regards
to surface water drainage specifically
that's going off that uh hard surface
it's not being infiltrated into ground
and there is an interceptor in place and
that's the drainage strategy that has
been added in for the the confirmation
that it's got to be built in accordance
with thank you chair uh thank you in
council crimson
thank you uh picking up on uh quite a
few of things that have already been
said um i i do feel that there isn't
already um a fair amount of this kind of
business in that area
um including not only mcdonald's down
the road but you've got the canterbury
bell the hood and horse
and tescos and numerous others i think
this is
an extra one that do we need
um but also my other main concern is
that
this is a loss of one
what's left of a little bit of green
space in what i still think of as an out
of town shopping center
i can't call it a town centre i'm sorry
and it's environmental poverty
to lose that visual
bit of green
and i i would hate to see this developed
even though we've got a few bushes and
some wildflowers
it's not going to make up for the fact
that you've got this chunk of a of a
development
um that is now going to be added into
what is already
a very very built up area and the loss
of
just that environmental poverty issue
the loss of the green space so
those are my thoughts on it thank you
uh thank you uh cancer effort
thank you chair yeah i mean i i share
the concern that this is an undesirable
development but i'm not really hearing
anything which amounts to to grounds for
refusing permission personally i mean we
have to consider this application on its
own merits and we have to look at his
incremental impact on the overall
situation not consider what how many
coffee shops there are
or how many vehicles might be going to
other things in the immediate area
um so i i would be concerned if this
committee rejected this application
because i think we would struggle to
justify um that refusal i mean what does
concern me a bit is that clearly at some
point um the overall scheme or that
particular part of westwood has come
before um the council for consideration
and no doubt that green finger has been
identified as a positive benefit of the
previous proposal and now of course
someone else comes along and says oh
what a good idea we can develop that
piece of land
which does make a bit of a nonsense out
of the whole thing but i i think
personally we would struggle to reject
it and whilst i don't welcome it um i
don't think that would be a sensible
thing for the committee to do thank you
uh thank you for that counselor
if i may i know i don't normally comment
because it's yourselves but
this piece of land um
which i'm aware of as we all are
has over the years been a massive
problem with
litter
the pathway that goes as it's been
mentioned from
the margate road onto the tesco site
and there has been massive issues over
that some members here might recall that
um
and
i'm not i'm not even coming to anybody i
do understand what counts forever is
saying here there's somebody coming
along
with another unit
um first in kent so i'm you know reading
the documents and so on
um
but obviously it's up yourselves uh it's
only out of interest what i've said
there
uh council wayford
thank you chair
um
i agree with a lot of things that
council overt said uh i think we should
be looking at this application
in its own right regarding things like
air quality it's relatively small
development
and i think it's very very important
that
there will be job opportunities offered
i think they've got to come from
somewhere
i think that yes we've lost a green
space but it's been replaced with a wild
flare
flower garden
soft landscaping there's a
great consideration for bio diversity so
i feel it's a change rather than a loss
um and as i say i for the economic
development
concerned i i feel we should support
this application
thank you council auburn
yes thank you chair um question
first can you advise why it's going to
take a year for the electric vehicle
points to be put in
yeah so what i've been advised is um
obviously you're probably aware that a
few of these units within and broadcast
retail park are vacant and so
the um
the the owners of of the site are
basically looking at what they're going
to do with this site into the future so
it may be that there's some refiguration
taking place of those units and it may
also look at the refiguration of the car
parking area so what they're concerned
about is putting any parking electric
vehicle charging points in
and then
that having to be aborted because
they're having to change
change the um layout so that's why
they're looking at um this this year
from the opening of the unit before
those were put in so they can have time
to look at how that site is going to be
used and how they're going to fill those
units
so
is the reason why they're not
within the
development sites
because there's not enough parking
spaces in that site would that be
no sorry so they're not within the site
itself because um i mean we did
initially ask them to be within the
actual site itself and that's normally
what we would go for
um but the advocate or the agent has
advised or suggested that because the
um vehicles using the site are going to
be quite short stay vehicles it's
unlikely to be as beneficial as if they
were to be placed in the large car park
so there's no electric vehicle charging
anywhere in that i'm aware of in the
tesco car park or the board says retail
park car park and as you can see the
size of those is massive so it's
actually more beneficial to actually
have the spaces for electric vehicle
charging in those car parks and
therefore we can again it's in terms of
shared links people would park there be
able to go to the retail units go to
that
um
that cafe unit whereas with only the 22
spaces in there they're going to be more
linked to just people using that that
unit rather than sort of a large area so
that was that's the reason behind it
thank you chick and i'll just
finish a couple of points if i may um
so
i'm mindful of what council of ghana
started off
when with his uh comments
um
and
my
concern was in relation to
the loss of that
of
the trees etcetera but having read the
the
the tdc tree officers
comments that is very happy with the
amendments made and please thank them
for taking on board my recommendations
for plants these will help improve the
aesthetics and biodiversity
i'm happy with the additional trees to
help mitigate some of the tree loss so i
think for that particular issue that
overcomes that and the trees that will
be going back in will help migrating
birds uh
just the same as the current ones are i
know they've got to grow etc but they
will do that
um and also the the wild flight the
wildfire the wildflower
areas are
again in my view
um
to
the green area which uh which is which
is the chair had said you know i know
you know it is full of strewn
rubbish and it's never cleared
um except your volunteer will come down
and do it you know we've i i know the
council before andersen's test goes to
come and do it um
so i'm i'm reasonable i'm reasonably
happy about that my my real concern was
the the
the impacts of this development on the
adjacent
house
the nearest house but you've said it's
88 meters away is that from the building
thank you chad
thank you for that council robin
councilwing
thank you chair i mean i'd like to
support a lot of what mike said actually
i don't think we and there's no offense
meant to anybody but i think we've all
got to change out the way we think we
cannot say it's just grass because grass
is an important
uh early level of biodiversity it
contains all sorts of bugs and worms
that the other other animals further up
the food chain require so although i am
concerned about the loss of trees and
it's good to see that the trees there's
a greater number of trees going to be
put in than lost i have real concerns
about about the loss of grassland
particularly in an area where there is
hardly any grassland there
which is is sad
so we need to we need to start thinking
about biodiversity is not just being the
trees and also a lot of the trees that
have been planted around there i i don't
think there's any guarantee that any
business is going to look after their
trees once they've been planted because
they tend to plant the cheapest saplings
and then they don't look after them and
there's lots of examples on that site
where trees haven't been looked after
and have died
going back to the grass i mean with the
whole most of the area i mean i would
say about 99 of that area
that was grass is now going to be
covered over with either building or
tarmac um is the tarmac porous or are we
just creating a more of a flooding issue
and there are a number of flooding
issues on that site in heavy rains one
outside marks and spencers for example
so is the is the tarmac porous will the
will it drain through i don't know
uh the pollution we moved westward
crosses moving from a place where you go
and shop and go home to a pla more of a
leisure area where where people tend to
sit down and eat so although we don't
have to be concerned with houses that
are further away maybe we do have to be
concerned with the fact that we're now
encouraging people to sit in an area
where there is a constant flow of
vehicles in and out to buy things and
also the charging points we've got a
situation with the new audi on boundary
road those charging points should have
been in before the shot was opened and
they're not and some eagle-eyed locals
have uh have made that complaint and i
know planning a gratefully dealing with
that i i i don't get a year for charging
points if you go into parts of london
there's charging points out of lamp
posts there's there's lump there's ones
that are on posts i think that's just a
delay in tactic by the business i i
don't think it's
particularly a massive cost considering
that build so i think we definitely i
won't be supporting the project but if
we do we definitely should be insisting
on the charging points being in at the
same time as the development
i think for that counselor keane
how's the common good
thank you chair
it's um can i just ask
has there been any objections from those
neighbors
well done
so
sorry i was it's watching councillor
allman turn yourself
um
the
i do understand what people are saying
about grassed areas
but i think we've got to take into
consideration it was a huge grass area
before it became westward cross
and when we talk about
people coming up there to do shopping
there are i'm not sure it's going to
increase traffic
because people will choose then whether
they go to mcdonald's or starbucks or
hortons
that will be people's choice
and personally
i think that 70 jobs is a lot of local
jobs
so i will be supporting it thank you
thank you how's it coleman cook
okay members i can't see any other hands
raised so i can put this to yourselves
um the officer's recommendation as
you've heard is for approval those in
favor could they please show
those against
that is carried thank you members that
those
no ascensions i don't think
beggar pardon heather sorry
that was carried
thank you members that concludes
the meeting for tonight um
thank you for times always officers
thank you